what's up guys hope you're all having a
beautiful day and welcome back so as you
can tell obviously tell by the screen
titanfall 2 multiplayer tech test has
been released it is supposed to be going
on for this weekend and then it should
be going on at the round the same time
next weekend so they're giving us two
chances to play this which is nice
because it helps the developers figure
out what's wrong with their game and
then if they need to improve on things
or not so basically if any of you have
never played titanfall before the basis
of titanfall is that it's like a
first-person shooter where the player
controls these people called pilots and
then these pilots as shown on the front
of the screen here earn enough XP in a
game and then once they earn enough they
will be able to call down the Titan who
is the big fellow in the back the Titan
definitely is a big change in the game
because he's super huge and there's only
certain weapons that I do lots of damage
to it which you do have the chance of
using obviously they have their own
secondary category for you to pick if
you choose but i'll be going over that
later in this video but basically the
basis of this video is what is the TAC
test what it's doing and what is in it
everything you need to know about it so
to start off you we have three game
modes for the two for this weekend pilot
versus pilot is the first one it is
basically a 8v8 team deathmatch where
there are no Titans it's just straight
pilots nothing else and the second game
mode is bounty hunt I didn't get a
chance to play this yet but I do know
from seeing some gameplay of it that it
is basically two teams fight over to see
who can get the most amount of points
every time you kill a grunt like an AI
you get about ten point like ten dollars
its money actually when you kill a pilot
it's a hundred and about halfway through
the game a Titan will spawn
and the money value for it is like five
hundred dollars it's a huge change to
the game that could definitely determine
who wins or who wins or who loses in the
game this next game mode is hard point
PowerPoint there are three objectives a
B and C 1 team spawns on a the other
team will spawn on C and B is neutral
once you start the game you basically go
to your objective and capture it now you
can stay and keep it captured once or if
you capture it a second time what it
will do is it will amp it when you amp
it as it says by the title it will give
you double points if whether you kill a
Titan kill a pilot getting assists it's
double points which is nice because the
objective of the game mode is to see who
can get the most amount of points I
think it's like the first 2 400 points
and that takes like six or seven minutes
roughly in the games I've played there
is one thing that they didn't keep in
titanfall which I did like and once
again for anybody that hasn't played it
you understand right now at the end of
every game the winning team will win
obviously the losing team will lose but
the difference is that the losing team
like the first game will have to go to
this spaceship it's called the epilogue
if the losing team loses they evacuate
to a spaceship and get shot back to
their base it's like the retreating or
the other retreating what you could do
and since this is the epilogue it is
like a search-and-destroy if you died
during the epilogue you cannot respawn
if you are the attacking or if you're
the winning team and you win the game
obviously you can destroy the ship and
prevent everybody from extracting or if
they don't destroy the ship you can the
losing team can get on the ship and go
back to their base I don't exactly
remember if you get any points for it I
think you get XP for extracting or
blowing up the ship every time that I've
played a game in hard point I've always
ended up losing sadly but my the enemy
team has not shot down the ship I don't
exactly know if there's a health bar yet
because I didn't see it but I think in
the bowl times that I played it did get
shot up a decent amount so either it was
super
close the dying or just doesn't like
blow up anymore which would be very
upsetting because it's kind of the whole
reason the next thing we have is
customization each pilot will get a
tactical ability that changes the way
that their character looks there's the
pulse blade which is kind of like us
it's a sonar pulse which if you throw it
on the ground it kind of surveys the
area and you can see any enemies through
this ah through like buildings and walls
the next one is grapple and the
grappling hook is basically what it says
grapple up to a building and you just
kind of you can either latch onto the
building or you can just kind of wall
run on to it whatever i'm not a big fan
of this though the hollow pilot which is
a it creates a holographic copy of
yourself which is cool because I've been
tricked by this about four times in the
past five games that I've played and I
still don't I still can't get around it
the the last two abilities aren't yet
unlocked stim and cloak but you do get
credits I don't exactly know what the
call think they're called merits merits
or credits I don't know what they're
called but you do earn these and then
you are have the ability to get the stem
and cloak as uchitel on the top right I
have 46 merits so I need 65 stim as you
can tell heals you and boosts your speed
which is nice but you do regen your
health but stem makes it faster cloak
which I would love to try out so I need
to get to that after this it be you
become nearly invisible increased
effectiveness vs titans because seeing
is Titan so big and you they see like
the whole field and pilots are super
small compared to titans being invisible
just super just like is really effective
you are also given for ordinance type
grenades the frag grenade which pretty
basic it's frag grenade the arc grenade
which is stuns pilots and blinds titans
so kind of like a flash type of grenade
a electric smoke grenade which carpets
the area with electric smoke
I haven't used that yet but I would
really like to try that out after this
and then the other one is the gravity
star poles enemies in and projectiles
before exploding during the once you've
loaded up titanfall there was at one
scene where it showed a bunch of
equipment for the Titans and it did show
this guy throwing this star grenade at a
wall and it kind of sucked everyone in
and it put them all together and it made
them completely vulnerable I will
definitely be using that now you're
giving a wide variety of weapons for
this game which is beautiful you have a
salt rifle SMG LMG sniper shot gun and
Grenadier although it isn't much you
have multiple different types of guns to
use there's only one assault rifle which
you start with in the beginning of the
game the are 201 carbine kind of your
basic assault rifle nothing to different
there the car standard SMG I'm pretty
sure that was in the first game I
believe the alternator which I can't
unlock it but it is a twin barreled SMG
you get to LMGs this Spitfire and the L
star 1 a 2 sniper rifles the the crabber
AP sniper and the D to double take which
is a twin firing sniper you get one shot
gun which is the mastiff and you get one
Grenadier which is the EPG one now to
the secondaries you get one pistol the
re 45 auto which is a just a regular
pistol none of the smart pistol [ __ ]
from the first game which I couldn't
stand but in the secondaries you have
three weapons that are used against
tightens and tightens basically Titans
only the LG 97 thunderbolt which shoots
a ball of electricity it's a very
slow-moving ball two so it's I didn't
think it was as worth it this one is a
charge rifle which is basically you
charge up the gun and then shoot it at
Titan it's like an ant it does it says
auntie Titan sniper and then this one is
the magnetic grenade launcher I'm not
exactly a big fan of this it doesn't
have a
lot of range but I understand that its
magnetic so probably sticks to Titans
but for right now I've just been using
the charge rifle the you also get two
types of kits you get kit one which
comes with a power cell which is faster
cool down kit the second part is health
regen begin sooner and then the third
one is you can quickly teleport into
your Titan you for the second kit you
have three abilities as well you have
wall hang which hangs onto walls by
aiming so when your wall running and you
just hold the aim button you can just
sit there kind of confuse enemies a bit
instead of dropping the second one is
enemy death locations marked by skulls
on the HUD which is a kill report and
then the third one is hover which aiming
while airborne allows you to hover which
I guess gives you better accuracy when
you're aiming and once again will trick
someone because they will move the
crosshair down thinking that you were
going down but you're really just
hovering that's all it is for the pilots
now for the Titans we have two Titans
ion and scorch now you can obviously
clearly read these abilities I can't
I'll I'll just put up scorches stuff
while I talk about him scorch is a
really big Titan lots of damage not a
lot of mobility which they kind of keep
it balanced like that that's standard
titanfall more damage but less mobility
what I figured out is that he's mostly a
flame person like incendiary type of
flamer which makes sense of his name is
scorch you can just read his abilities
there if you want to pause the video and
look the next one is ion once again I
read his abilities while I talk but he
has not a lot of damage but a lot of
mobility and then we also have the
armory which has the two abilities you
can call in once you've get enough
experience you can call on these two
abilities so far in Nevada which
supercharges your weapons and then the
next one sends drones that actively seek
out enemies and then kill themself
factions I thought was an interesting
idea it's a little bit more interesting
than it looks basically there's two
factions the apex predators and the 64
now there are actually two teams that
are fighting against each other in the
multiplayer which happens to be apex
predators and 64 now you can actually
choose what team you want to be on by
selecting the factions that will
actually put you on that exact team
every single time I have put on the 64
and I've been on the 6th floor every
single match which is nice it just helps
you like queue up with friends I guess
they happen to be in the same one and it
doesn't cost anything to change just you
can just go to faction click a and it's
perfect for call sign we have four
banners which I'm not going to I don't
have them on lock debt but these are
what they look like they also have a
bunch of patches which also go on the
bottom left these are clearly what they
look like and then you get in boxes I'm
going to get to these in like four
seconds what they mean but the next
thing you're given is networks I am
joined I joined the advocate network
which has the most amount of players
unlike all the networks but the advocate
network is kind of like a hub where
people can talk and just kind of have a
conversation with anybody like once
again via the messages or if you want to
talk and chat I haven't exactly figured
out yet how any of this works there is
something that keep popping up that's on
the top it says happy hour and it starts
in 10 minutes outside 10 hours I heard
from what it is is that you earn more
merit or not worth the currency of the
game when you play during happy hour
which for me would be around midnight
other than that that's basically
everything we have other than that guys
that is basically the titanfall 2 tech
test I have an idea for a video coming
soon besides this one but other than
that guys I hope you guys did enjoy like
like the video if you enjoyed comment
your opinion and also comment down below
what you think of the tech test I think
I'm going to start doing a lot more
tight and fall in this channel probably
going to just stop from overwatch I'm
really starting to enjoy titanfall it's
just so much fun to play I'm so glad
they made a second one I enjoy I loved
the first one other than that guys like
that like I said like the video comment
your opinion on the tech test and
subscribe if you're new I will be
putting out a ver a new video shortly uh
shortly in the next few days if not
definitely next week but um once again
guys have fun and peace